Flight 56, service to London City Heathrow Airport.
On behalf of the 9000 employees that are based here in Miami,...
...it is our pleasure in having you aboard this beautiful Sunday afternoon.
More than just words, especially the time that we live in today in 2010,...
...thank you for your business and thank you for flying with us.
It's more than just a slogan.
The hardest part of your journey is now over:...
...that is the boarding process.
We have that taken care of.
This evening on board, we have an excellent International Miami and Raleigh-Durham cabin crew.
They're here for the next three hours on your way to the United Kingdom.
We do ask that you sit back, relax,...
...we'll have you under way momentarily for our flight to London.
Welcome aboard.